on Capitol Hill this morning lawmakers
are racing to pass a trillion dollar
economic relief package that could send
direct payments to millions this comes
as the Trump administration has been
sending mixed messages on the
possibility of a coronavirus drug and
O'Keefe joins us from the White House
Edie where does the relief package stand
right now well good morning Dana
negotiators are set to meet again later
this morning to continue hashing out the
details Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
says he hopes that the Senate can vote
on this package by Monday and late last
night lawmakers on both sides said
they're making good progress senators
here we're working and we're going to
deliver on Capitol Hill senior lawmakers
negotiated late into the night on a
massive stimulus bill that would give
financial relief to Americans in the
wake of the corona virus pandemic we're
gonna get help to the people not just to
help the people but we got to get our
economy moving again the Republican
written package would send direct
payments of $1,200 and provide loans to
small businesses in hard-hit industries
like the airline's
the federal government is gone under I'd
probably 70% on the payroll in this
country if the containment policies
continue to be disagree so nobody's ever
thought of that before nobody's ever
done that before
it's gonna be a hell of a lot more than
one trillion dollars but the bill
requires bipartisan support to pass in
the Senate Democrats are demanding more
benefits for the jobless with some party
leaders claiming the bill is friendlier
to corporations then workers let's
really focus on America's workers who
will be the first casualties if they're
laid off or have to take sick leave this
tremendous spirit to get something done
so we'll see what happens the ongoing
debate comes as President Trump is ruled
out or during a national lock we're
working with the governors and I don't
think you I don't think we'll ever find
that no system and he announced a
virtual shutdown of the us-mexico border
just days after mostly shuttering the
Canadian border to curb the spread of
coronavirus the measure and all of those
measures that we're putting in place
will protect the health of all three
nations mr. Trump repeating an
anti-malaria truck was a game changer
may work may network I feel good about
it it's all it is just a feeling you
know I'm smart guy but standing next to
the president Anthony found the nation's
top doctor and infectious diseases
offered a reality check it might be
effective I'm not saying that it isn't
it might be effective but as a scientist
as we're getting it out there we need to
do it in a way as while we are making it
available for people who might want the
hope that it might work you're also
collecting data that will ultimately
show that it is truly effective and safe
under the conditions of kovat 19 last
night the White House announced that a
staffer to vice president pence has
tested positive for covert 19 a
spokeswoman for the vice president said
that the staffer hasn't come into close
contact with the President or vice
president we may learn more details
about this at the latest White House
Corona task force briefing later today
Jeff ed O'Keefe at the White House said
thank you